hello everyone and welcome back to the
first American chess congress the good
stuff we are back at the fourth game
between Paul Charles Murphy and Louie
Paulson so after three games the result
is is even score our first game when two
more feet than that the draw were more
feel reversed the move order and then he
lost all the balls and his first loss in
the first American just Congress is his
last we'll just have to watch its till
the end and see and hear now he has the
white pieces so without further ado
let's check it out and thank you all for
joining the HS team arena today sorry
didn't work out leeches service crashed
but will will will do it better next
time hopefully so getting to the game
morphe opened with e4 and Paulsen
replies with c5 he goes for the Sicilian
defense we have Knight to f3 e 6 and now
d4 sorry about that and seek after Sundy
for of course with Knight characters in
the Bishop to c5 now going after the
night and now instead of Knight b3 first
Bishop to e3 just defending in bish and
the Queen to b6 now putting more
pressure here also threatening the the
pawn here but here more fee goes Knight
the b5 and here he's offering Bishop
captures on e3 for Paulsen to win a pawn
however if you go after this captures
captures and capture some more fee
blocks you're kinda in in trouble here
and there's no clear way on how to
defend all of the checks for example you
could go King d8 but then you lose
castling privileges and the white just
continues and he is very happy to give
up his pawn for for such a game of
course there are even crazier ideas like
Queen captures and then check you pick
up the Queen but okay Knight to f6 by
Paulsen and Bishop captures in c5 now
morphe eliminates the bishops Queen
captures in the night the d6 check and
it is as of MOVEit that this position
has never been reached again the black
king is in check you have to do
something King to e7 and this is there
are lines even today that are played
that allow this check working goes to e7
and it's actually an okay position for
black and such as this one here we have
Knight characters here as the night was
now under attack
so rook captures developing the rook and
Bishop to d3 morphic continues
development and Knight to c6 Paulsen
does the same
we have castles and now as Morphy
already said that he will Castle
kingside Paulson doesn't have a king
sized castle so he starts marching his
pawns forward we have h5 morphic
continues with the development in 92 and
now h4 not wanting to allow h3 morphic
pushes h3 himself and now g5 it is
Paulson who is coming after morphe at
this game we have a three more faeces
nothing really going on here I'm just
gonna play a pawn move and indeed if you
g4 you can just capture it the Queen
also guards g4 so first the Paulsen
prepares it and now b4 first you get rid
of the Queen Queen to b6 and now Knight
to c6 again with an attack on the Queen
improving the position of your night
Queen back to c7 all the way back and
now f3 just strengthening g4 here so
Paulsen starts improving the position of
his pieces Knight to e5 and morphe
trades with a knight captures Queen
captures and now Queen to d2 preparing
the bust open the position with f4 rook
the g7 with ideas of maybe doubling
rooks on the G file and rook a to d1 now
if the bishop moves and for example this
night isn't here maybe ideas like Queen
captures and b7 will be here so rook to
b8 more Paulsen defends the d7 pawn and
Queen to F do now still f4 is an option
but also you're just threatening to pick
up the a7 pawn we have be 6 by Paulsen
defending and now f4 are asking a potion
what do you do here we have characters
on f4 more fury captures now offers the
Queen trade and now Queen to g5 pause
and says yes let's trade Queens but I
want to trade Queens and g5 so I can
just double nicely here and the G file
morphe says no thank you rook to f2 also
defending checkmate as there was the
threat of checkmate and now Queen
captures an f4 by Paulsen with rook
captures on f4 and rook beat the g8 now
not the defending the h4 pawn but rather
going for a counter-attack so rugby -
Morphy defends it and now rook the h8
balls and also the
his h4 point and now II five by Morphy
he five is a maybe a bit of a suspicious
advancement of the pond but he will keep
d6 + f6 under control so black will not
be able to to use these pawns so
tonight's the d5 with an attack on the
rook rook to d4 again the two rooks will
will put some pressure on the decent
pawn if CC 4 is played
so first f6 it's time to get rid of this
a five point each characters on f6 would
check Knight captures and now we have
looked a c4 I worked the c4 hoping to
get rook to c7 in there are no there are
no discoveries here with the two rogues
going after as the knight defends the d7
pawn now so there's no point Roxy for
hoping to get rook to c7 in but King to
d8 Paulsen prevents it and now a four
more feet continues pushing and the
material is equal one difference that is
notable that Paulsen has two points in
the center of the board whereas morphe
doesn't and morphe has two-to-one
advantage on the King side so it's a bit
of a bit of a different position but all
in all would perfect play neither player
shouldn't be able to do anything about
it so tonight the d5 by Paulsen and now
push up the e4 the bishop will nicely
defend the g2 pawn and also it's on a
beautiful diagonal here we have Knight
back to c7 and now comes a bishop back
to f3 and finally d5 by Paulsen we have
looked the c6 now putting pressure under
on the e6 pawn here and now comes a rook
to d7 preparing to push the d5 the D
pawn Bishop to g4 putting pressure on
the e6 pawn now and rook to h6 defending
as morphe continues piling up on the e6
pawn but King to e7 and there really is
no no good way to take advantage of this
so first King to h2 more female prepares
g3 he wants to get rid of Paulson's
h-bond and he wants to create a passed
pawn and the King said so he can start
pushing it King to f7 and now g3 of
course as planned each character skin
captures and rook to e7
now unpinning now the e pawn can also
move
as the bishop no longer threatens to
pick up the rook we have aged for more
free containers pushing the pawn and
knights the eight now Rema nuvaring the
night with h5 by Murphy and Knight to f6
now with the threat of just Knight
captures here to get rid of the pawn so
what was more fees idea here his idea
was a rook captures on e6 he trades his
past h1 for the very strong central pawn
we have group captures Bishop characters
with check King to g7 and now Bishop
back to G for getting the bishop out of
the way but now you've freed the the e7
square for the rook so not much you can
do here you have to go for the pawn
Knight characters on h5 we have Bishop
characters rook captures and rook the e7
check now King f6 and rook captures an
a7 and after all of this after some 47
moves a more fee is now up a pawn in a
rook same game
so King g5 Paulsen with a bit more
active king and rook to a6 now going
after this pawn as well we look the g5
check King f3 Ruka 5 check King to e2
not allowing d4 to come with check and
now b5 saying that ok I'm gonna lose the
point either way so maybe just let's
double up more response here and
although morphic can play a 5 capturing
here is is even better there are no
dangerous here
so rook to f4 going after more fees b4
pawn but now c3 and here Paulsen goes
for d4 and now you're more fee here feel
free to pause the video how do you win
the same game well I'll give you a
couple of seconds I'm sure you don't
need a lot of seconds but you know have
some if you need so for those of you who
decided on b6 that's that's insufficient
for example if b6 captures you're gonna
put b7 rook captures here and there is
no way to promote your pawn this is only
a draw and for those of you who decided
to advance the pawn that is the way to
victory so congratulations
and now the the connected passed pawns
are simply too strong here at rook to h4
was played by Paulsen but now c5 we
looked the h2 check King d3 now comes a
series of check by poles and rotations
recheck King C to rook h2
check King Tubby 3 and rook h3 check
morphe hides King to a4 and now if you
go d3 then rook the d6 you are not doing
anything with that beep on so Paulson
goes rook to d5 first but still rook the
d6 width check we have King to c4 and
now c6 more if he starts pushing the
passport we have rook the h1 more if he
has to be careful if something like c7
then rook to a1 is mate you don't want
to lose a game like this so more if we
could go for King a5 here hide the king
and b6 promote the CC pawn and it's a
game over but here
morphia I guess started to feel a little
bit better after that drawing round 2
and the loss in round 3 so decided he
decided to show off a little bit he
played rook captures done before
I mean who could blame him King captures
and only now c7 so Paulson of course
played rook to h8 we have b6 by Murphy
and now again King to c4 where he's
checking if more fees paying attention
or something maybe if King a5 then you
can again deliver rook to e8 checkmate
but here more free just of course play
b7 and it was in this position that
Louis Paulsen resigned the game so Game
four of their matchup in the 1857 first
American chess Congress it goes to Paul
Morphy here of course you resigned
because any movie black plays it's just
made unless you want to try it again
with rook to h1 to deliver checkmate
here and then maybe more fee instead of
bringing the Queen of which check brings
out the Queen out here and then you are
happy to deliver checkmate so it could
be an attempt but Paulson says yeah yeah
we're just gonna resign here so that's a
game for of their 1857 finals of the
first American chess Congress I do hope
you enjoy that a bit of a different game
it was actually Paulson who who came who
came aggressively for more few more feet
defended and then he somehow was able to
win upon and then he managed to win an
end game and the game lasted for 64
moves I don't have the actual hours how
long this game lasts but I do know that
Paulson again took a lot of time for his
moves but he did so in every game so
unless it's like incredibly long think
I'm not probably gonna mention that all
that much but yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoy that stay tuned for
five of their match I would like to
think I almost really are coach of dog
McNabb Kartik s Kenan and Kevin thorn
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it as
usual you can check - on my previous
video serum thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Morphy saga checking up
in your wonderful suggestions and so on
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day